bonsoir code blanchemaison merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france des
militaires birmans qui maîtrisent la
situation ou non dans le pays
quel est justement la situation en bon
militaire il avait parfaitement planifié
leur coup d'état
dès que les élections du 20 novembre au
produit les résultats que il ne pouvait
pas accepter puisque cette majorité très
importante pour le parti de madame aung
san suu kyi risque et lorsque
l'assemblée se réuniraient de conduire à
une révision de la constitution que les
militaires avaient écrites en 2008 et
c'est cette constitution qui prévoit
pour eux des sièges au parlement
vingt-cinq pour cent qui prévoient pour
eux que le ministère de la défense
ministère de l'intérieur et de l'esr des
frontières leur est réservé et non pas à
répondre aux chefs de gouvernement sur
ces sujets là et se gèrent eux mêmes et
aussi le fait qu' ils ont un rôle très
important en matière économique et que
le parti de madame aung san suu kyi
était bien déterminé à limiter ce rôle
et surtout à lutter contre la corruption
donc ils ont planifié le coup d'état
pour le 1er février puisque c'était le
jour où devaient se réunir ce nouveau
parlement
mais ils ont fait une grave erreur ils
ont sous-estimé grandement la la
capacité de lutte de la société civile
d'hermann probablement qu'ils étaient
mal informés probablement ils ont
sous-estimé le caractère inacceptable
d'un nouveau coup d'état en birmanie
pour la jeunesse est en effet depuis le
1er février
et bien la population birmane est dans
la rue et manifestent contre ce coup
l'état maintenant il ya une grève
générale et par conséquent le pays est à
l'arrêt on voit également que dans les
services publics mais bien beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ne travaille plus
certains policiers aujourd'hui ont
traversé la frontière en direction de
l'inde
et ça effectivement c'est un c'est ainsi
ça veut dire que les choses sont en
train de bouger
et peut-être que les militaires sont en
train de perdre la main mais bien
entendu le pays pendant ce temps-là
s'enfonce dans la crise et
malheureusement peut-être vers de
nombreux morts alors les femmes mais
aussi les jeunes quelle place tient-il
au sein de ce mouvement de contestation
mercredi le mercredi noir aux jours où
il ya eu 38 morts parmi ces 38 morts il
ya eu un vandale est une jeune femme qui
avait 19 ans qui marchait en tête d'un
défilé naturellement pacifiquement
puisque tous ces défilés sont pacifiques
il n'y a pas de casseurs dans ces
manifestations
et elle a été tué d'une balle dans la
tête là les militaires ont voulu faire
une expertise et faire croire qu'elles
avaient été tués par des manifestants
puisque la balle est entrée par
l'arrière de sa tête en réalité c'est
parce quand elle s'enfuyait lorsque les
militaires ont commencé à charger et
aujourd'hui elle est un peu l'icône de
l'icône delà de la lutte de la lutte
pour la liberté contre la junte
militaire
et puis tous ces jeunes évidemment son
sens en jean en basket et le chef de la
junte a cru utile de dire que que ces
jeunes ne serait ce que par leur
attitude leur habillement ne respecte ne
respectez pas à l'autorité des
militaires et ne respectaient pas les
traditions birman en effet il ya un
décalage dans le temps une sorte
d'anachronisme guerman les militaires ne
connaissent plus la société birmane
d'aujourd'hui alors que peut faire dans
ce contexte la communauté internationale
face à ce bras de fer en birmanie il n'y
a pas vraiment de communauté
internationale ou s'il y en a eu la
halle et pluriel puisque depuis
plusieurs jours on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord au conseil de sécurité
des nations unies sur le texte d'une
déclaration d'une simple déclaration il
s'agit même pas d'une résolution pour
l'action mais la chine met son veto à
tout texte parce que
elle ne veut surtout pas ouvrir la porte
à une éventuelle intervention extérieure
quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit à l'onu
où que ce soit tout sous toute autre
forme
et puis en même temps elle appelle au
dialogue parce que elle défend ses
intérêts qui sont importants en birmanie
et notamment ses investissements dans ce
qu'on appelle le corridor nord-sud qui
relie en fait directement la chine à
l'océan indien pour les autres pays et
bien les états unis de monsieur biden
ont sanctionné neuf généraux qui font
partie de la junte
c'est à dire que leurs avoirs sont gelés
la grande-bretagne en a sanctionné trois
de la même manière qui s'ajoute à ce que
l'union européenne avait sanctionné
lorsque l'héroïne gars avaient été
chassés de leur territoire
et puis l'union européenne s'apprête à
prendre des mesures complémentaires
d'une part sanctions contre certains
chefs militaires et d'autre part
peut-être d'ici à fin du mois c'est les
ministres des affaires étrangères qui
devront décider interdiction de traiter
avec les entités économiques qui
dépendent directement des militaires ou
de leurs familles et là effectivement ça
risque de faire un peu plus mal aux
personnes concernées
parce que le gel de leurs avoirs à
l'étranger est un peu symbolique ils en
ont ils en ont pas en tout cas dans les
pays occidentaux
peut-être en ont-ils en asie mais ils en
ont pas dans les pays occidentaux en
revanche l'interdiction de faire des
affaires avec des groupes des
consortiums qui de près ou de loin
appartiennent aux familles des
militaires
ça risque de les frapper davantage alors
dans tout ça il ya quand même les
voisins autre que la chine et dans les
voisins autre que la chine il y à alain
il y a les pays d'asie du sud est asean
dont la birmanie fait partie
et puis il ya un autre groupement qui
comporte la birmanie et la thaïlande
deux pays aujourd'hui très peu
démocratique mais aussi tous les pays
d'asie du sud c'est à dire
l'un de ces longs le bangladesh le
bhoutan le népal et c'est peut-être du
côté de la zad et du côté de ce deuxième
groupement dont le sigle un peu bizarre
s'appelle bim steak c'est peut-être de
ce côté là que certains pays pourraient
jouer un rôle pour essayer de restaurer
un dialogue qui permettrait en effet
d'éviter l'effusion de sang
mais en réalité les possibilités de ce
dialogue sont sont bien fait puisque les
militaires sont tout à fait déterminé à
écraser la contestation a écrasé la
l'opposition à leur coup d'état
merci claude blondeau maison pour votre
analyse